from 20th Century Fox comes a landmark
of science fiction filmmaking that's
still one of the most shocking movies
ever met wait we're doing the Tim Burton
version let's just get this over with
Planet of the Apes prepare for a reboot
so disappointing the franchise was
immediately Dee booted then rebooted
again ten years later
watch as the once visionary Tim Burton
he was a master class in how not to
reboot a franchise as he attempts to set
his film apart from the 1968 classic by
repurposing old dialogue Nick your
stinking hands off me you damn dirty
human repeating no dialogue dan dan oh
and trying to one-up the original ending
even though his makes absolutely no
sense
huh when an Air Force captain abandons
his orbital monkey research station to
follow his pet ship into an electrical
storm bah-bah-bah time travel blah blah
blah evil monkey Society problem
uprising ancient monkey prophecy final
battle and the creepiest kiss ever trust
me you won't remember the details either
witnessed a hundred-million-dollar
version of Mark Wahlberg talks to
animals I just follow your sequence and
come home
understand in his lowest point since his
rap career as he spends this entire
terrible movie staring at things
phoning it in hey where am I
I was here a few days ago and
mouth-breathing
but he's not alone marky-mark shares the
screen with a whole funky bunch of other
actors like a bunch of humans were
supposed to care about but doe Estella
Warren's dumb face and more Oscar
nominees in monkey suits than the
Academy Awards and the Oscar goes to
nobody
so before you catch the sequel to the
way better reboot get ready to suffer
through everything you didn't want from
a Planet of the Apes movie featuring
political debates a human problem cannot
be solved by stinky throwing money at it
the government tried that once and all
we got for it was a welfare state that
nearly bankrupted us lucky for play and
Apes going hey what do you know about my
father
how the hell did these monkeys get like
this
starring say hi to your mother for me
Bellatrix Lestrange duh
Michael Clarke Dunston checks in
reservoir gym a monkey in apologia muddy
suit and a GRU ham Ligon Planet of the
Apes the bad one damn you our thoughts
exactly
be sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers Apes together strong I'm going
to punch you into space how much wood
could a woodchuck chuck if a woodchuck
could chuck norris shut up and take my
money go
Oh